i grew up with you
like well i
dude you were my babysitter my mom would
just like leave ytv on
and it was you
and now here we are that's so awesome
and now here we are and i've been
watching you the last couple days i'm so
excited for you thank you man
i know would you is it fair to say that
you're probably like the biggest marvel
fan to actually be cast as the lead in a
marvel property yeah
yes
yes
what is like the wildest marvel thing
that you own that you've purchased with
your own money that you have ooh
i don't i not purchased i stole a lot
from our show
the first episode of avengercon
the first day we went to to film it my
assistant and i went around the entire
stage and were taking photos of
everything i wanted to steal and on the
last day i was saying bye to people and
she was putting things in bags and we
shipped everything home and i have just
so much stuff it's great
can i tell you i appreciate the honesty
because whenever the idea of like hey
did you take something from set comes up
when i talk to people they're like i
don't know if i can say it
you offered it up you're like yes i
stole all these things it's amazing so
how much would you say i mean like
kamala is this teenage girl on a journey
of self-discovery who's a massive fan of
avengers and captain marvel like how
much would you say you connect with her
on a personal level
a lot i mean it's it's the whole reason
i fell in love with the comics you know
she was this muslim pakistani superhero
nerd and i was a muslim pakistani
superhero nerd and
she just spoke to me on such a cellular
level and and it was more than just
being religious or being you know in
touch with your culture and your roots
she she truly understood fan culture in
a way that really elevated her story and
you know having a comic book kind of
motivate and encourage fans to continue
to make fan art and cosplays and and
be active on mcu subreddits like it's so
important and being an mcu fan is so
much work like we're 34 projects in
it's a lot of content and it's a lot of
comic books you have to read up on so i
just i think our show really
encapsulates all of what being a fan is
and is kind of a love letter to that and
so i really hope it connects to people
in that way
so did you have the the mindset of
because you're such a big fan and you
are really connected to the fan culture
i would say probably more so than a lot
of you know your other uh mcu co-stars
did how did that affect your mindset
going into making this
well i was a walking mcu encyclopedia so
anytime anyone needed any help it was
like where's him on yeah okay um but no
it was just
i don't know i mean i i have such a deep
connection to the source material and so
does a lot of the other you know our
creatives our muslim and south asian
creatives just
felt kamala's story on such a deep level
and we wanted to just make her character
as specific as possible and
specificity is representation you know
you can't just have one brown person on
screen
generalize
the two billion muslim and south asian
people into this one character and call
it representation you know making a
story that's so detailed and and
studios showing that they understand and
they've done their research about
someone's culture
that's like what's progressive in my
opinion so i i think you know down to
the music we've really got this
character to be as you know realistic
and as authentic as possible
i love that yeah and when kamal came out
on page like she
spoke to so many people and now you're
here doing this and
you're co-starring with you know people
that you've been looking up to are you
like texting with real arson every day
now is that what's happening
every day now i'm still kind of
intimidated by her which is weird
because i've like known her for two
years now and we work together but um
no she's she's been so wonderful and the
fact that she was the first person to
reach out to me after i got cast and
just
kind of talked to me give me the lay of
the land what am i gonna expect coming
into all this and how to take care of
myself was was so helpful because it's
so easy to get caught up in all this and
sell your soul to hollywood so yeah i'm
i'm happy
i love it you know i know that they're
gonna be uh you know millions of young
canadian kids that are looking up to you
that are going to see you as a hero but
for you who is your hometown hero
oh god hometown
michael sarah i don't know
like a canadian that yeah canadian that
you
have looked up to
oh god i don't know i have i have an
iron man shrine i'm like literally my
whole focus is robert downey jr
so
i'm sure there's canadian people god i
should have prepared better for this you
i'll say you me oh get out of here come
on
you know stop all right just because i'm
here but i appreciate that anyways i
would say maybe robert downey jr citizen
of of planet earth
honorary canadian citizenship yeah 100
yeah dude so proud of you so happy for
you thank you i'm really excited for
this thanks for taking the time of
course thank you so much
you